bonsoir direct sur rt france la
communauté internationale tout d'abord
qui boudent cette conférence
ce n'est pas une surprise effectivement
la situation est telle que vous la
décrivez elle est en trois volets n'est
ce pas il ya un volet a effectivement
humanitaires sociales si je puis dire
il ya un volet économique et un
troisième volet politique le retour des
réfugiés ne peut se faire qu'à partir du
moment où il y a un retour que vient
d'être expliqué à l'état acceptable des
infrastructures mais pas seulement mais
de la vie économique du pays donc il
faut des investissements
or les investissements ils ne peuvent
pas être assurée seulement par la russie
il faut qu'ils soient assurés par les
pays arabes il faut qu'il soit assuré
par l'union européenne il faut qu'ils
soient assurés par les états unis
or ces investissements là nous pourrons
être fait que dans le cadre d'un
règlement politique
troisième volet est donc il ya un
certain nombre d'investisseurs possible
qui souhaitent le départ d'appel de
bachar el-assad de bachar el-assad donc
vous voyez vous c'est un dossier
effectivement très compliqué le retour
des réfugiés nécessite des
investissements mais les investissements
doivent passer par une évolution de la
situation politique a comme l'a dit
d'ailleurs vladimir poutine il faut que
toutes les troupes étrangères quittent
la syrie et comme l'a ajoutée a ensuite
alexandre la grande nef le lendemain
l'iran y compris dont vous voyez où la
situation est loin des saints alors
quand on dit quand l'union européenne
des crimes réunion prématurée est ce
qu'on peut vraiment s'exprimer en ces
termes elle est vraiment prématuré selon
vous cette réunion au nom des trois
volets que je vienne présenter
effectivement il faut qu'il y ait des
avancées sur le volet politique pour que
ensuite il puisse y avoir des avancées
sur le volet économique et que dans ces
conditions le plus grand nombre possible
de réfugiés puissent revenir dans leur
pays les populations
ils payent le prix la situation est
extrêmement compliquée sur le plan
économique en syrie le régime a sa part
de responsabilité n'est ce pas je crois
que les 380 mille morts et les sas les 5
millions de personnes qui ont fui leur
pays à son doivent être assumés par le
régime de bachar el-assad dont quitte ce
n'est pas ce ne sont pas les pays
extérieurs qui doivent assumer la
totalité de la responsabilité politique
vous dites une transition politique est
nécessaire on l'a on l'a bien compris
aujourd'hui quelles sont les conditions
à réunir pour cette transition politique
précisément il faut qu'ils aient une
acceptation de par moscou a
effectivement de trouver un moyen
élégant que bachar el-assad puisse
quitter le pouvoir
à partir de ce moment là je crois pas
qu'il ira à une ouverture politique
importante et que l'ensemble du
mécanisme dont on vient par eux dont je
viens de parler en trois volets pour a
assez rapidement se mettre en place
au coeur de cette reconstruction
évidemment c'est tout l'enjeu le retour
des exilés
quelle garantie selon vous offrir pour
permettre ce retour en sécurité
le retour en sécurité c'est la mise en
place dont de ces trois volets si il y
avait le départ de bachar el-assad
il y aurait la possibilité dans un temps
relativement rapide de débloquer
quelques dizaines de milliards sachant
que la reconstruction globale de la
syrie est estimé entre 80 à 100
milliards enfin donc ce sont des sommes
tout à fait conséquente
d'où la nécessité que la communauté
internationale y participent et que les
desiderata de cette communauté puisse
s'exprimer et être concrétisé à savoir
l'évolution du pouvoir merci gérard
vespière analyste géopolitique chercheur
associé à la fondation d'études pour le
moyen-orient merci d'avoir été
avec nous